constant readers are aware that the
words Arts and Sciences are part of the
Academy official name the next award is
a category which combines both art and
science special visual effects it'll be
presented by the most talented Beauty
who ever came out of the woods miss
Natalie Wood
Wow pretty thank you Bob you're so
knowledgeable about moviemaking would
you explain what special effects are
special visual effects while there are
explosions fires volcanoes eruptions
earthquakes and then of course the more
subtle effects while in my new picture
the private navy of sergeant Oh Phil
there's a scene where Gina Lollobrigida
I make passionate love on the beach as
the tide sweeps over us and what was the
special effect are getting the tide come
in no getting Burt Lancaster not to sue
us the nominees for best achievement in
special visual effects are lb Abbot the
doctor Doolittle and Howard a Anderson
jr. and Albert Whitlock the Tobruk and
the winner is
lb Abbas the doctor Doolittle
I want to sincerely thank all the
wonderful people that made this possible
you